[Music]
has there ever been a female godzilla
so this question goes hand in hand with
godzilla's sex is the kaiju a male a
female and it or something else entirely
of course the king of the monsters is a
guy and with the word king there is no
doubt but has there ever been a female
of his species
and also if he is actually a he or
something more
please bear with us and i do think this
topic is going to offend many fans it's
a bit shocking but we have to do it we
have to set the question straight
watch till the end for a conclusive
answer let's discuss on why we got here
and break down each godzilla at a time
now let's get to it
the main reason as to why this topic is
so crucial is because of the existence
of godzilla's sons in the form of manila
from the show era and final wars
godzilla junior in the hasty period and
even phillies in the anime where did
they all come from if godzilla was a
male even the monster was godzilla where
did he come from was he born or did he
slowly evolve over time and transform to
this nuclear monster we see today if
there was no child or successor to the
king we wouldn't have even thought about
it the g-man would be accepted as a
one-of-a-kind kaiju born out of
radiation due to nuclear testing and
nuclear waste and maybe evolution in
some cases
in the showa era godzilla was always
seen as agendered by honda and other
directors who didn't give the monster
agenda
so with the 1967 movie son of godzilla
manila that ugly beast turned the entire
thing around there have been some that
have come to believe that godzilla was
in fact the mother of that child it
might sound funny but
the confusion is real although godzilla
was the parent of manila it isn't known
whether the g-man laid the egg or
another female kaiju of the same species
did it something that was never answered
and if there was one it was never shown
or talked about this is why many chose
to believe that godzilla was in fact
female
and there is another school of thought
another group that believes that
godzilla was neither male nor female but
hermaphroditic that is godzilla has both
male and female parts in him it whatever
in the heisei period however the baby
godzilla born in godzilla vs
mechagodzilla 2 was known to only be an
adopted child and not directly related
to godzilla as it was late in the
prehistoric times by another
godzillasaurus during the time of the
dinosaurs and the living thing in it was
killed where the dinosaurs were killed
but then in modern times it was revived
by nuclear radiation that irradiated the
egg enough for the creature to turn into
another godzilla of course being a baby
godzilla so in this version the baby
godzilla did have a mother but it was a
dinosaur and not a nuclear reptile that
was transformed in recent times
so we can clearly say that the big g in
the hasty movies was in fact a male and
the foster father of the baby godzilla
junior
so now we come to ziller the one from
the tristar movies this version was in
fact female
even though they said it was a male and
the creature can reproduce asexually in
reality in certain circumstances and
conditions a reptile can reproduce
without the need for bang bang and one
example that we know of is that of the
komodo dragons they reproduce true
parthenogenesis this occurs of course
only in females though not males
parthenogenesis allows the females to
lay eggs without the need of a male to
fertilize them however unfertilized eggs
are in fact males
so when the hatchlings grow up the
female then mates with the males to
produce more females and males and so on
so if this was to be extrapolated into
the tristar movie then zilla even though
hermaphroditic in a way was originally a
female its offsprings however were all
males
so one of the only times this question
would have been answered properly
was in the case of godzilla the animated
series a female godzilla was one of the
few monsters that were prepared and
planned for the show but was later
rejected and never utilized and though
there were sketches made of it they
never made it into the series
and these sketches were given names
based on other toho godzilla monsters
the creature was supposed to appear in
the episode end of the line but it was
substituted by commodore tracks because
the producers didn't want another
godzilla on the program and comothertrax
was a female komodo dragon heavily
irradiated in the same way as zilla and
even had similar powers but you know
godzilla was an iguana here and this was
a commodore dragon so not the same
species
now the heisei films introduced the idea
of godzilla cells having a powerful
regenerating factor called the g1
regenerator so perhaps at a certain
point of time godzilla just spawns an
offspring or an egg asexually now that
would have perfectly explained the
millennium godzilla which came out many
decades after the death of the original
this would clearly show that godzilla
was in fact asexual
at least in the case of the original one
this godzilla and even the anime trilogy
one as well as shin godzilla were all in
fact asexual neither male nor female and
they can also spawn offsprings by
cellular division
godzilla phillies was the son of
godzilla earth and came out from
cellular fission so were the fifth forms
of shin godzilla you know the tiny
humanoid godzillas that was seen to
about to emerge from the tail of the
fourth form
so now we come to the master verse
godzilla
this version was always referred to as
male and even michael doherty the
director and co-writer of godzilla king
of the monsters a sequel to the 2014
godzilla and the 35th film of the
franchise
was unequivocal in his response it's a
he
he's called the king of the monsters
there was no offspring to confuse the
crowd in this one the monster was g-man
is undoubtedly a male titan and so was
another one of his kind the long dead
5416 adam or also known as dagon but
here in this franchise there is quite a
big possibility for the existence of
female godzilla's as well
since they constitute a super species
and were numerous in the ancient
prehistoric times up to a point where
they were killed by
war with the species of gongs and also
prayed on by demuros and many other
conflicts
so the thing about the latest godzilla
the one from singular point is that this
creature is a product of an archetypal
trans-dimensional matter and therefore
is something that supersedes the laws of
physics in this world and is something
above sex and gender even above
asexuality it was seen first as a
gigantic aquatic reptile chasing a group
of serpentine kaiju called mandus then
it transformed into an amphibious
creature then again transformed into a
gigantic dinosaurian monster and at the
end became a superpowered kaiju this is
similar with the case of shin godzilla
but shin has mata from this plane of
existence and wasn't trans-dimensional
in nature as compared to singular point
godzilla
so let's count them down the show era
godzilla was asexual or quite possibly
hermaphroditic the heisei godzilla was
no doubt a male zilla from the tristar
movie was hermaphroditic and would have
originally been a female since it got
pregnant and has the organs for egg
laying the fact that it was
hermaphroditic was due to the ability to
fertilize its own eggs zilla from the
animated series was male although there
could have been a female zilla but the
idea was crap millennium shin and the
anime virgins were all asexual with the
ability to produce young via cell
division
singular point was just weird and
trans-dimensional and lastly the monster
was godzilla was male as a male the king
of the monsters
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam